Oh, I'm not lurking.
Lester wanted to inspect the peep holes
because evidently some of them had been
installed backwards. So I said, well, I'll do
it. And he said, you know, the good time is 2
a.m., so I'm lying. I just wanted to say I'm
sorry.
Oh. Apology accepted. Friendship mended.
You're hired. No, no, I don't want to do this
show. I just want to hang out.
Of course we'll do that all the time. Eight
shows a week and Broderick, you're fired.
Wait a minute. Wait.
This guy. I've seen him get out. Acted by a
horse.
Maybe he was, but I'm guessing that horse
enjoyed himself on set that day because he
got to spend it with Charles Hayden Savidge,
who was probably kind to him and fed him a
fistful of oats out of his palm. And I bet
that horse didn't realize how good he had it
until he had another scene partner on another
set who just wrote them and wrote them and
wrote them and wrote them and wrote them and
wrote them and wrote them until he couldn't
take it anymore.
And I bet that horse wishes he could say
sorry, but he can't. Not because he's a
horse, because he's a little messed up
emotionally, so all he can do is hate himself
and and wish he were dead for hurting his
best friend and that someone would turn him
into glue.
Apology accepted.
Okay, okay, I'll do the play.
By the way, that horse won a patsy for that
scene.
What's a patsy?
It's an Emmy for horses.
You're still here? It's over.
Go home.
Go, you know, if you have any adjustments.
I'm very flexible and I've always found it's
best to be honest.
I bet you would have made a much better.
Faris. Do you mean that? Oh, I want to, but
he's perfect.